jornada sangrienta en sudán al menos
seis personas murieron este jueves
durante las protestas contra la junta
militar que gobierna el país
desde el derrocamiento de omar al bachir
en 2019 la imposición de un gobierno de
transición y posterior destitución de
este en octubre pasado el país ha vivido
una crisis política constante en los
millones que han salido a las calles
desde el 6 de abril de 2019 han tenido
como objetivo lograr un estado civil
pleno donde la autoridad sea el pueblo
que esta revolución sea popular y que
regresen los soldados a sus cuarteles
durante las protestas se ordenó bloquear
la señal de internet y el corte de las
líneas telefónicas las autoridades
militares tomaron medidas drásticas para
que las multitudes no llegaran al
palacio presidencial a pesar de la
represión las masas no cejaron en sus
reclamos
la gente tiene que confiar en sí misma y
nunca retrocederá hasta que sus
objetivos se cumplan y el pueblo sudanés
tendrá la victoria sobre los generales
la víspera 13 representaciones
diplomáticas incluyendo la delegación de
la unión europea instaron a las
autoridades militares a garantizar la
libertad de expresión y la protección de
los civiles en las manifestaciones según
el comité de médicos de sudán gente que
se dedica a contabilizar y atender a las
víctimas los fallecimientos se elevan a
109 desde el inicio del golpe